FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS
CONVERSATION, IT'S A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER WHOSE INTERESTS
ARE VERY DIFFERENT THAN OURS AND
IT IS.
JORGE RAMOSE IS AN AUTHOR.
THINGS WERE COMING ON.
I UNDERSTAND MY MEXICO WANTS TO
EXPORT TO THE UNITED STATES.
IF WE COULD SPARK EXPORT TO
CANADA, WE WOULD DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY AMERICA IS
DENOUNCED AS RACIST FOR NOT
WANTING THAT.
WHY IS IT RACIST TO SAY IT'S OUR
BORDER, WE DETERMINE WHO COMES
HERE?
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET ME SAY I
DON'T SPEAK FOR THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
I'VE BEEN CRITICIZING THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
SPEAK FOR THE MEXICAN GOVERNMEN
GOVERNMENT.
WHAT I DO UNDERSTAND IS WHEN YOU
HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING THAT
MEXICO HAS TO PAY FOR THE WALL,
MEXICANS DON'T LIKE THAT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A POLITICIAN IN
JUNE OF 2015 SAYING MEXICANS ARE
CRIMINALS AND DRUG TRAFFICKERS,
MEXICANS DON'T LIKE THAT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT LET'S BE HONEST.
IF YOU WERE DEALING WITH RACISM,
MEXICO IS RACIST.
IT'S A TOTALLY UNEQUAL SOCIETY,
WE ARE NOT ATTACKING IT, BUT I'M
SAYING --
>> THERE'S ANOTHER
DISCRIMINATION.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO
ATTACK MEXICO, I THICK A
PERSPECTIVE IS IN ORDER.
IT'S A LITTLE MUCH FOR THE
OFFSPRING OF CONQUISTADORS TO BE
SAYING YOU'RE A RACIST IF YOU
WANT TO BORDER.
BY THE WAY, WE DESERVE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
THIS IS CRAZY.
CAN WE BE HONEST ABOUT IT OR NO?
>> THERE'S DISCRIMINATIONS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES AND MEXICO,
ABSOLUTELY.
THE UNITED STATES DON'T HAVE A
RIGHT TO A BORDER.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT, BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT BRINGING THE
MILITARY TO THE BORDER IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A WASTE
OF TIME AND RESOURCES, THE SAME
WITH THE BUILDING THE WALL
BETWEEN BOTH COUNTRIES.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS A LEGAL
SYSTEM THAT WORKS AND IT'S NOT
WORKING RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: THERE'S NO DOUBT
IT'S NOT WORKING, BUT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS WE NEED TO
LEGALIZE EVERYONE THAT SNUCK IN.
HOW ABOUT YOU SAY THE
UNITED STATES HAS A RIGHT TO SAY
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORKERS
ALREADY, WE DON'T WANT ANYMORE,
HOW ABOUT THAT?
MEXICO SHOULD STOP ALLOWING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS TO CROSS THE LENGTH
INTO THE U.S.
MAYBE MEXICO CAN HELP WE WOULD
NEED TO WALL.
>> THERE'S TWO POINTS HERE.
ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE HERE BECAUSE OF THIS,
THEY'RE DOING THE JOBS WE DON'T
WANT TO DO, SO THAT'S ONE POINT
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK WE HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
TALKING ABOUT SOCIAL AMERICANS
CROSSING FROM MEXICO TO THE
UNITED STATES, THE UNITED STATES
AND DONALD TRUMP REALIZE THAT
THEY NEED MEXICO TO CONTROL
IMMIGRATION.
MAYBE IT'S MEXICO'S BARGAINING
CHIP.
I THINK AFTER TRYING TO MAKE
MEXICO PAY FOR THE WALL, NOW HE
HAS TO REALIZE THAT AFTER ALL
THE ATTACKS AND THE INSULTS, HE
NEEDS MEXICO.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN THE UNITED STATES,
MEXICO WOULD COLLAPSE.
AS I SAID, IT'S THE SINGLE
SOURCE OF LARGE CURRENCY IN
MEXICO.
PROBABLY NOT MORE THAN A
FOOTBALL OR COCAINE, WE DON'T
BUT WHY CAN'T WE BE HONEST AND
SAY MEXICO WOULDN'T EXIST
WITHOUT SENDING ITS POOR HERE
AND WE SHOULD CALL ON THEM TO DO
SOMETHING TO CONTROL THE BORDER
AND IF THEY DON'T, WHY WOULDN'T
WE WILL BOLD THE WALL?
WHERE IS THEIR IN THIS?
>> THAT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STORY.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THERE
ARE OTHER RESOURCES.
IT'S NOT THAT MEXICO --
THAT'S FALSE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AMERICA'S
FAULT TO A SMALL DEGREE AS WE
SPEND AN AWFUL LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO IMPROVE COUNTRIES
ACROSS THE GLOBE AND NOT ENOUGH
PAYING ATTENTION TO
LATIN AMERICA.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT IS
DYSFUNCTIONAL AND ITS LEADERS
STILL THE MONEY AND LEAVE AND
HAVE HAZARDS IN SWITZERLAND, SO
WHY DON'T YOU AND PEOPLE LIKE
YOU AND ME TOO PUT PRESSURE ON
THE GOVERNMENT AND THAT WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO SEND 11 MILLION
PEOPLE HERE?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT.
I'VE BEEN CRITICIZING THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT FOR
CORRUPTION AND I'VE SAID THIS
GOVERNMENT MORE THAN 100,000
PEOPLE WOULD BE KILLED JUST IN
THIS GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CANNOT STAND
AND WHAT I'M NOTICING RIGHT NOW
BY HAVING DONALD TRUMP
CRITICIZING MEXICO AND MEXICANS,
IT SEEMS THAT HE'S HELPING THE
MOST ANTI-TRUMP CANDIDATE TO GO
OUT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN ELECTION
I THINK ARE VOTING IN.
CAN WE AGREE ON THIS POINT, A
COUNTRY THAT EXTERMINATED ITS
BLACK POPULATION THAT IS RUN
EXCLUSIVELY BY WHITE PEOPLE THAT
HAD A CASTE SYSTEM BASED ON
BLOOD, UNTIL PRETTY RECENTLY,
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T BE CALLING US
RACIST.
CAN WE TAKE THAT OUT OF THE
EQUATION?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK WE SHOULD CRITICIZE MORE